- I think people are
demonizing social because it's
showing us who we are in a way
that we aren't excited about.
I believe that we are all gonna
become way less hypocritical
of each other once we all realize
we all have shit in our closet.
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
(light music)
Massive, audacious perspective
and deep practical capabilities.
Double Ps, if you can have perspective,
proper macro perspective
and you can have micro practionership,
you will be happy and win.
I really believe that.
Having the humility and the audacity,
back to your contradiction,
but that's how I got to Clouds & Dirt
because I've always been
fascinated by that about me,
which is the things I'm
willing to do right now
that are below my pay grade.
This podcast, this is super scrutinized
by the people around me.
They're like, why are you doing this?
We don't have 15 minutes
for very important shit.
You're letting money, opportunity, VIPs,
why are you doing this?
I don't know.
Intuitively, when we were
talking I thought it was
a good idea and I think
in my massive perspective,
giving back...
Look, you're going to leverage
me being on this show.
- [Hassan] Absolutely, for sure.
- And that makes me feel good.
That's me giving back.
This is a bigger thing,
giving you these 15 minutes
than me giving you $15,000 for your app.
For me, it's easier to write the check.
For me, humility and perspective,
I don't know how many very
busy people are running around
knowing that they need to put change
into the bucket of giving back
in their time, not their money.
(light music)
- Good.
(laughing)
I believe that.
Look, I'll be honest with you.
I don't believe the current school system
is such a great proxy to
success and happiness.
I really don't.
Now, he could be doing bad
in school for bad reasons,
but keep going.
- [Winner] Which I understand,
I barely made it out of school.
- So, you have empathy.
- Yeah, but I don't have
empathy for laziness.
- Okay, and how lazy
were you, do you know?
I mean it.
How real are you willing
to get with yourself
because me and you have 43 and 44,
17 feels like yesterday, but
your Monday through Friday
52 times, hard to remember.
And the other thing is the
next cliche thing that's gonna
come out of your mouth is
your hard work has probably
put him in a place
where he has the ability
to have more entitlement than you did.
- [Winner] Yes and my
thing is, you know what?
I don't care if you don't wanna be...
I can't expect you to
be a straight A student.
If you did, that's cool, but
at least have some energy
to do something else--
- Listen, can I tell
you what I'm gonna do?
So, there's no better advice
than eating your own dog food.
Mine are younger, but as
long as you sit them down
and say, my man, and you've
gotta decide, 18, 22,
you can do it forever,
but if you say, do you,
but here's what's up.
When you turn 18 or when you turn 22
or whatever the heck is
gonna be in your house rules,
you're out.
You're out.
I'm not giving you a dollar.
So, I'm giving you, back to
your game, a year, three years,
five or whatever you're
doing and you wanna live
with 13 friends and you're
gonna become an NBA player
or a rapper or an entrepreneur
or whatever, mazal tov.
But I'm telling you to
your face out of love
I'm not giving you any money.
Kids are lazy because they think parents
are gonna take care of them
and parents take care of them
because they don't want
judgment from others
that their kid's a loser.
- [Winner] You're right.
- The end.
I don't care if other parents
think my kids are losers.
I'm not gonna build a
fake environment for them
because then they'll never
be achieving anything.
You made a good video, D-Rock?
(laughs)
Really?
I like Samson.
You've been cold.
(pulsing music)
Heading now to dinner with
the Vayner productions team.
One of the things I'm trying to always do
is spend as much time
with my team as possible.
So, a nice little dinner
with seven or 10 or 15
of the leaders in production,
which is a big growing part
of our business at Vayner.
- Yeah, I think it's helping.
- [Guest] You think it's helping?
- I do and I think everybody
thinks more like you.
Social media's not changing
us, it's exposing us.
- [Team Member] But it's
also enhancing parts of us
that weren't necessarily present.
- Correct, I think the word
exposing versus enhancing's
an important one.
I think it's what people
thought the whole time.
What do you think was happening
in Greenwich, Connecticut
in 1987?
It was playing out in a
country club in the whispers
in the darkness.
I think people are demonizing
social because it's showing us
who we are in a way that
we aren't excited about,
but all those infidelities and
behaviors and all those other
things were happening and by
showing it in the same way
that I want you to come
and tell me, not hide it,
it gives us the ability
to start addressing it
in a different way.
I believe that we are all gonna
become way less hypocritical
of each other once we all
realize we all have shit
in our closet.
I understand where you're
coming from and I promise you
way more people agree with you than me.
My take for the record in
perpetuity is it's the best thing
that's ever happened.
We will eat crow for a
generation, but over time,
it will lead us to a much better place.
I really believe that.
Look, I think communication
solves everything.
- [Guest] Agreed.
- Great, so what we're doing
right now is we're grappling
with the communication tool of today.
Hip hop, Neil, you've
heard this from me, I think
because you're a little
closer to my content
and what have you.
I love that hip hop...
If you said to me for your
life, your life, your life,
you have to get a bunch of
14 to 18 year old white girls
in America to do something in six years,
I'd literally start with
Atlanta hip hop artists
because I know that
they are the influencers
of that behavior.
I've gotta make them do something,
build it and then tweak it
and then I can get every 15
year old white girl in America
to do something by starting
with Lil Baby and Gunna
29 months earlier.
I think that's powerful.
I think certain people harness that.
If you even look at the way
Jay-Z navigates his life,
he understands it because
he's on the court.
I love that.
Who actually has the power?
I'll tell you.
You want me to throw you for a real loop?
I rarely say this, Jason knows this
because he listens to everything I say.
I don't like sharing this
one because it's too early.
I'm confident on my
hypothesis on this is good,
which is why I share it.
I'm not as confident about
what I'm about to say,
but fuck, it's building
and soon you might hear it
from me consistently in a year.
I have a weird suspicion that the internet
and the current state of America
is disproportionately
skewing to the have-nots.
That the middle is being
squeezed, that the end that
doesn't give a fuck who
your granddaddy was.
No granddaddy donates to the
fucking library of Tulane
and now the kid goes to play
on the Tulane football team.
Shit goes down with the leverage of money.
The internet just fucking plays.
It's why SoundCloud rappers
are the biggest rappers
that emerge.
Nobody's in charge.
There's no A&R guy
anymore that's like, you.
(light music)